foreign
[Music]
strong enough to have it all
too weak to take it
foreign
Ty
it's choking you
can't you feel it
it didn't work
Carmen was right he got it from you
that's pathetic sickness
I'm gonna fix you
hey Run please
later Peter no good deed goes unpunished
you can thank me later
[Music]
oh my god oh man you should you should
get out of the car everybody get off the
bridge
[Music]
hello Peter
why do we do I know you what have you
done with my machine
I don't know what you're talking about
all of my hand
gone what is
listen we can work together and I can
help you find your machine do you want
to play a game
foreign
[Music]
should have killed your little
girlfriend when I had the chance
say yes looks like we got competition
thank you
[Music]
don't worry ma'am I'm coming
thank you
[Music]
Sam just stay calm just take a deep
breath are you okay
I promise I've got this all under
control
[Music]
give me the Box
foreign
that might be one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to me but don't
ever do that again
[Music]
hey get off of me
thank you
[Applause]
it is the season
[Music]
what is this place the mirror Dimension
where I'm in control
[Applause]
talk about this Parker don't you realize
that in the Multiverse there are an
infinite number of people who know Peter
Parker is Spider-Man and if that spell
gets loose they're all coming here look
I know I get it but we can't just send
them home to die it's their fate you
can't change that any more than you can
change who they are but what if we could
what if we could change their fate
hello what are you doing
I'm not giving you the clue
give me this back
wait a minute is that an archimedian
spiral the mirror Dimension is just
geometry you're great at geometry you
could do geometry
Square the radius
along the curve over Parker
I'll come pick you up when it's done
hey strange you know what's cooler than
Magic
math
don't do this
ow I'm sorry sorry but
[Music]
I have to try